are you the type of guy who's totally
comfortable letting it all hang out or
are you more of a never news no no
shower I'm like oh God no no I'm not
I've never been comfortable are you you
I bet you hello we saw you with David
Letterman right you were you're fine
with
letting it
you know it's funny I was um I'm so glad
that I had an uh an unuptight
exhibitionist hedonistic free hippie
Wildflower like era because I am a
cloistered nun now I like being exact
opposite
like all the girls want to wear the crop
tops and I'm like not on your life Olive
your daughters no like not ever going to
happen when you're 18 you want to wear
crop tops you go right ahead so I'm I'm
so glad that I was Freer at some point
yeah because I'm not now yeah